[Music]
all right earlier this week I spoke with
superpower director sha Pan about the
ongoing war in Ukraine now we spoke
about Europe not paying their fair share
so many countries they're not in it to
win it especially Joe Biden and yet was
sending billions and billions and
billions uh why did they have an
intention to win the war well anyway
here's part two of our interview take a
look look you kept going back there how
many times you been back now uh as of a
few days ago it was my eighth time okay
so you you're going back you're putting
your life in war zones I've been in war
zones not comfortable
feeling you're with the number one
target when you're there or you get when
you get to
calinski convince conservatives you
know why why should if Europe won't St
up step up and protect their own
continent which INF doesn't that
infuriate you that infuriates me it does
does and if we're all at the beach and
somebody's kids's drowning and nobody
else is going in we still got to go get
them Fair answer I'll give you credit
however Europe needs to we need to
demand that they do their part demand it
and insist on it I think that's part of
what I when I'm talking about decisive
leadership I don't think that and and
and also when I'm talking about this
citizenry look forget the differences in
our party or
politics we have to demand of leaders of
the media
context Clarity decisiveness
leadership I think that we're in an
environment where leaders uh in
different ways you know what my the
offense I take at um what I would call
um the Trump culture mhm which has very
little to do with anything Republican
that I
remember um it's actually very
similar an awful lot more populist and
an awful lot less um realistic about
Russia and more romanticizing of strong
men but that that's and very afraid very
cowardly in the face of Donald Trump and
that's that and and what happens is you
going it's an example no I'm talking
about the culture because I think the
great danger in this country
is that leadership is not
encouraged and and neither citizenry
it's all become a mish masat that's got
everybody so confused that of course
with something as clear as the Ukraine
war and everything it has to do with our
principles as a country our aspiration
as a country that we would fade on that
is only is only a reaction to this
distraction When Donald Trump took out
the caliphate you know what they wiped
him to Smither the caliphate all during
the Obama Biden years grew grew grew
grew grew territory territory and he
wiped him out one by one is this when he
invited the Taliban to Camp David you're
talking about no I'm talking about let's
talk when Donald Trump did Trump focus
with me just track with me on this when
he beat the califate because this is a
part of what people want and it actually
fits into the words that you use
regarding 9/11 he fought it to win it
and he won it and it was overx
expeditiously he wasn't playing games
with the caliphate and similarly if
Ukraine had had the support of Europe
and Joe Biden didn't veto Jets and
everybody did their part and everybody
stepped up I think we would be in a very
different place today than where we are
do you think the calip is over oh I
think he blew him into smithin I think
they're trying to rebuild for sure I
mean you know evil exists and is going
to pop its head up you know in any form
manifestation name whatever it takes on
radicalists you know they're there
radical islamists are a threat to the
country and what's the origin islamist I
think it might be but you said you would
have personally extra judiciously
murdered 9/11 terrorists if you were
president so that's like the Trump doct
more what I felt is that a president to
be able to to give the context to give
leadership at that moment look you we're
both like this if somebody says you know
something like oh it's America's fault
that this happened however if we're
being if we're going to actually move
the ball forward well what I wanted to
see of a president was somebody said you
know what I'm I'm I'm not going to
consult White House
counsel I'll just so you know I'm with
you I'm killing talking about 911 I'm
talking about 911 I wanted President
Bush to basically say if I have to go to
jail I'm going to jail but I'm spending
sending special operators in now we're
going to kill
them after that he can say things that
will reach across the globe and see that
that we recognize that the capitalist
exercise this experiment like any other
system is an experiment has its flaws
too and it makes things harder for for
some countries that are in the shadow of
harder than they have to be and that
there there was a way to kind of
globalize the messaging and keep not
only keep Unity here after 911 but it
start to build a Unity that also would
collapse calipat because people are so
desperate and they they and they and
they do they think that the other guy is
crazy and then but when it gets to
actual violence like this if we're not
willing to say that there is an origin
to it then there is no collapsing of
anything it continues so that's what I
was talking about I I did want I did
want
the victims and and psychologically or
literally the victims in their families
I did want them to know that this was
not going to stand much more clearly
than a random war in
Iraq that had no connection to it
whatsoever hey Sean Hann here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else